they these are Nazis essentially trying
to exterminate Jews and they are
embraced by black lives matter in
Chicago it is disgusting what is
stunning to me is that the black lives
matter organization on the national
level has not denounced this they have
said nothing they decapitated babies
shot and killed babies raped women
killed women took hostages slaughtered
families in their homes these are
disgusting vile terrorists that's all
they are and that picture the reason we
know about the paragliders is Hamas
they're the ones that released the video
of the paragliders cuz they were so
proud of the Carnage good good good good
and true credit where credit is due like
I don't really care about all the gossip
and all the rest of it